qué le pareció el desfile extraordinario
maravilloso muy imaginativo precioso
como siempre fue de la moda a cambiar el
mundo No lo sé pero Fue genial
[Música]
pero sí
si eres perspicaz y entusiasta puedes
cambiar el mundo me encanta Estela me
encanta la moda de Estela
me encanta me encanta como ella siempre
ha apoyado la causa a favor del medio
ambiente
Estela es un ser humano muy especial y
eso se nota en su ropa para su colección
pretapocté del verano 2023 Estela
Mccartney eligió desfilar al aire libre
y además en aras de la inclusión
permitió que una multitud de curiosos
Viera una de las colecciones más bonitas
de la temporada
esta temporada hemos añadido algo muy
importante que nunca habíamos hecho
antes y no estoy segura de que alguien
lo haya propuesto en una pasarela
tenemos algodón regenerado que hemos
estado trabajando con soctas en Turquía
durante tres años es la primera vez que
usamos algodón regenerado esto quiere
decir que es completamente biodiverso y
que estimula la naturaleza Qué es lo más
sorprendente de todo esto esencialmente
incluye la naturaleza en el proceso en
lugar de destruirla por completo con
todos los pesticidas y cosas por el
estilo normalmente somos 100% algodón
orgánico pero hemos introducido algodón
recuperado en algunas piezas y es
simplemente increíble esto significa que
captura todo el carbono del suelo no
deja huella de carbono puedes
comprobarlo es una de las cosas que
hemos mantenido y también tenemos las
pieles falsas los zapatos veganos todos
los materiales de origen vegetal y luego
hemos vuelto a trabajar con piel de
hongo que es genial y sacamos los
primeros bolsos hechos de falso cuero de
micelio que más tenemos solo un montón
de cosas
es mi hermana Gracias hermanita
siempre está haciendo cosas nuevas
Así que es emocionante verlo porque
siempre es algo que no ha hecho
[Risas]
la conocimos en el desfile del joven
prodigio de la moda Víctor vensanto
Micaela stark nacida en Australia
actualmente reside en Londres es
diseñadora de lencería y artista
plástica el material con el que trabaja
en sus obras no es otro que su cuerpo y
esto obviamente no es una coincidencia
empecé como diseñadora de hecho estudié
diseño de moda antes de convertirme en
costurera
Entonces me di cuenta de que a menudo en
la moda utilizamos la ropa para ocultar
nuestro cuerpo y para esconder las
partes del cuerpo que consideramos feas
o indeseables
por ello crecí con muchos trastornos
disfónicos no confiado en mi cuerpo
Así que intenté llevar ropa que ocultará
mi barriga o mis pechos intenté hacerme
ver bien pero nunca funcionó mis pechos
siempre se caían mi estómago tomaba
formas increíbles
crecí en la época de los vaqueros
ajustados y mis piernas parecían
delgadas y luego tenía esos bultos de
grasa que sobresalían en la cintura y
siempre se podía ver
y finalmente gracias a mis conocimientos
de corte de patrones pude transformar la
cosa para poder cambiar estas formas y
acentuarlas aún más
mi barriga parece gorda algo que parezca
aún más grande lo mismo con mis senos
voy a jugar con mi sujetador para que
quede alocado y se vea muy bonito la
moda de cierta manera me ha hecho sentir
peor pero al mismo tiempo me gustó tanto
que me hizo sentir mejor con la moda
puedes fantasear puede ser quien quiera
ser de verdad
la última vez que nos encontramos con
Lilia litkovska acababa de abandonar
kiev una semana después del comienzo de
la guerra ruso ucraniana con su hija
pero sin su marido que se había quedado
a luchar desde entonces ha estado
trabajando en su nueva colección la moda
no es inútil la moda es una lucha
una gran parte de mi familia está hoy
conmigo
mi hija mi madre
mi héroe mi marido que es un oficial un
militar
fue herido y ahora se está recuperando y
nos apoya hoy
de hecho nunca se detiene
para mí la moda tiene que ver con las
raíces las tradiciones como decirlo las
fuentes
celebró la humanidad la sociedad la
economía el planeta
es como una exploración del mundo y del
tiempo pero no solo sirve para hacer
ropa
exploration
la moda no es solo ropa es un marcador
de tiempo
un revelador de lo que nos rodea
Esta es la Mccartney Micaela
tres mujeres para las que el diseño de
moda es un arma para luchar contra la
opresión todas las formas de opresión